okay so Blade Runner 2049 is one of my
favorite sci-fi films of all time and I
might even put it up there as being
better than the original
what yes yes I
ads for me but Danny will enough created
an incredible sequel that I think builds
perfectly on the first film whilst also
crafting its own story and characters
that don't feel reliant on the past it
also manages the naranga fans by [__]
up characters like Deckard and even
things like whether he's a replica or
not are questions we don't get answers
to feels like there's a real respect for
what's come before and throughout this
video I want to go through the film
scene by scene and point out all the
Easter eggs hidden details and things
you might not know about the world in
case you missed our Blade Runner
breakdown then there's a really
interesting backstory to this world that
doesn't really get touched upon in
either of these films the Blade Runner
universe is post-world War III in which
chemical and nuclear warfare were used
on the world and in the aftermath of it
the planet was highly destabilized
poisonous toxins were injected into the
atmosphere which killed most of the
animals and a large number of humans
were left with mutations and also
physical defects for example the first
film had GF Sebastian who we learned was
rap aging the sky was blacked out and
places like La rained all the time now
the movie even ends with it snowing and
throughout kadon's a big coat to keep
him warm because of how cold it is on
the outskirts of La we also have a
gigantic sea wall and this has been put
in place to counter the rising sea
levels now in his ride we see Kay
filling out a report at one point and he
does this on plastic instead of paper
due to it no longer being so readily
available very few trees exist on the
planet and this is why the one at the
farm becomes so important now the
plastic that he writes on also has a
1920s camera plate holder as well
showing how Humanity has had to resort
to modifying and recycling things from
the past although case jacket has
sheepskin on it the costume designer
said that they made a point of only
using fake fur in the clothing because
almost all the animals are gone this
could also be a call back to the book
that the series is based on called the
do Android stream of Electric Sheep
because we have an Android wearing an
electric sheep even though he's really
dreaming of Anna diama Scott damn anyway
the locations really speak to how messed
up the environment is and how damaged
that the planet has become thus Humanity
has taken to the stars and they've used
replicants as a way to scatter hazardous
planets the replicants were very much
slaves but they weren't seen as being
alive because they were synthetic when
they're killed it's also called retiring
because to kill something means that it
was alive as we saw in the first film
they were also given short life spans
and this was so that they couldn't
really do much with their life humans on
Earth were lured in a space with the
promise of every replicant and they
range from all types like the comet
drones like Roy to the sex slave
pleasure Bots like pris the first film
was very much about a hunter of these
named Deckard realizing that they were
human and learning to love one the
second film builds upon that and we
discover that he and Rachel actually had
a child together if Humanity was to
learn about this then this would create
more questions over whether replicants
are real or not and it would end up
leading to further disputes now we
actually see this play laying out in the
first of three short films that fill in
the events between the last movie and
this one much like the animatrix these
allow the backstory to be told to us and
hadn't actually seen them until I went
back to the film for this breakdown the
first is Total Blackout 2022 and it
tells of what happened with the
replicant models after that first film
directed by shinichiro Watanabe you
might know him as being The Man Behind
Cowboy Bebop his movie actually also
references that anime in its final few
shots and we have K dying on the stairs
similar to spike Spiegel now in case you
haven't seen it it basically talks about
how the Nexus 6 was replaced by the
Nexus 8. I don't know why we didn't get
an Axis 7 but it might be like how Apple
skipped the iPhone 9 so that they could
release the X in line with their 10th
anniversary anyway the Nexus 8 to a
given natural life spans then in
response to this human Supremacy group
throws up that sort of take them out the
replicant registration database was
created to identify them all but all
this information was lost during the
blackout the anime features a scene ref
thing on the first film and we watch his
gath and Brian go through replicant
profiles amongst these we see sapper
Morton and you might recognize him as
being played by Dave Batista now as we
later learned sappa delivered Anna and
in military terms as Sapp as someone
who's responsible for breaching walls
the infertility of replicants is at one
point described as being a war between
them and the humans and thus him helping
with the delivery very much plays into
his name now in the anime inuk's
detonated above la which creates a
blackout this destroys all the records
and we end with the character Iggy
removing his eyes so that he can't be
identified we learn that replica in
production was then prohibited and in
the wake of this the Tyrell Corporation
went bankrupt Leander Wallace then
acquired it and appealed the ACT which
takes us into our two other short films
2036 and 2048 both are actually directed
by Ridley scottson Luke and the first
Stars Benedict Wong and Jared Alito the
first one's about him repealing the
replicant ban and this is due to him
predicting that if they don't use slave
labor that Batman will hit the planet
replicants are the workforce of Earth
and even the word robot comes from the
word Robotnik which means slave neander
gets the replicant with him to
self-retire and this shows how he can
create them to obey even to the point of
their own end thus he sells them on
never running never rising up and
obeying Humanity to all ends realizing
replicants can be used as slaves once
more they left the ban and Wallace is
able to start producing more now Leto
provides a chilling performance
throughout the movie and this blind
character brings a number of symbolic
things with him firstly we see later on
that his Holmes adorned with large
inexpensive wooden walls we get an idea
of how much wood is worth from the
dealer later on when the tiny horse that
K gives over is said to be enough to buy
a real one as mentioned real animals are
almost extinct and this hammers home the
idea of how valuable this wooden horse
is the fact that Wallace's walls are
built with wood as well shows how
wealthy he must be and as we mentioned
earlier this is because there's so few
trees you also have his chilling eyes as
well and much like the first film may
carry a lot of meaning with them now the
first movie opens on a shot of an eye as
does this one this is green and as we
later learn Rachel's eyes were green too
her eyes were green
now the first film having a blue eye
makes me think that it belonged to
Deckard another second could belong to
Rachel I think it's more likely that it
belongs to their daughter Anna the film
opening with her eyes symbolizes that
she's the key to everything and it lets
us know that she's the most important
character replicants were of course
identified with their eyes in the void
contest and here we learn that they're
now identified by their eyes having
serial numbers Roy kill Tyrell by
pushing his eyes in and Roy even visited
an eye manufacturer mention this all in
our last video but we surmised that this
was done because eyes are the window to
the soul the how does his play into
neander Wallace while his eyes are
covered with metallic contact lenses and
these are allow him to see through the
use of drones a craft talks about movies
pointed out that this shows he doesn't
see the world through his soul but
rather through technology this gives him
a cold and emotionless view of the world
and having these tools also allows him
to be like an All-Seeing God Tyrell lost
his eyes in that very first film and now
we have a successor who doesn't eyes at
all replicants remove their eyes to hide
who they are and we also have joyous
whose eyes take an interesting turn in
the film throughout she develops what I
think could be genuine love for K but
she's eventually destroyed and we've
seen advert for her this ad spouts off
some of the lines her choice said in the
movie and she also refers to K as being
Joe you look like a good show
earlier in the movie this is her giving
him the name because he was special
whereas here there's a more Sinister
side to it being completely nude she's
clearly meant to be in line with a
prostitute and not to get into a
breakdown of hooker terms but men are
often referred to being Joes by them my
wife's my wife's not watching this is
[__] well I learned it from a movie uh
that bit now she referred to gay as Joe
at several points and this reveals that
the girl that he thought was special is
just a program designed to either love
him or at least make him think that she
does in the scene she also has black
eyes and this is possibly showing that
she's just a Solace creation built for
one thing her eyes are being Stripped
Away because this Joy doesn't have a
soul she's just a product that's built
to be consumed there's even a boy
version of her spelled b-o-i and these
products are made Sully to belly
isolation that people in this world feel
now the last short film is called 2048
and no prizes for guessing that this is
said one year before the events of this
film in it we found follow supper as he
protects a mother and child and in doing
soy out himself as a replicant and thus
has to go into hiding a one Pony shows
her the book of the power and the glory
which is about an outlaw priest who's
trying to understand what it means to be
human it's one of my favorites you'll
love it bit on the nose but the short
ends with a witness calling the police
to report supper as a rogue skin job
which sets up K hunting him down in the
movie yeah just getting a breaking down
the actual movie now that starts off
like the first one with a big block of
text by that they do something really
clever here and they have the first word
appear on the top left which makes our
eyes go to it this is also how
replicants are identified and they have
to look up to the left to show their
serial numbers at the heart of Blade
Runner is very much his idea of empathy
and learning to see the replicants as
human which puts us in their shoes they
are very much exactly the same as us on
every level except for that they have a
serial number on them somewhere where we
don't his texts crawl instantly puts us
in their shoes and makes us do what they
do from the start to sell really get us
to side with them it hammers home this
idea of empathy and K is even chosen
because of his lack of it which is what
the Baseline test checks for we now have
replicants hunting replicants and
originally they were designed to have no
empathy this is what the vodkom tests
checked for and they start to go Haywire
once too many emotional questions were
asked now after the shot of the eye we
cut to the fields of California to see
giant towers and panels these are laid
out in this circular motion and they're
meant to mirror eyes only this time
they're synthetic who watches K passes
over large fields of greenhouses and
though you might think these are fake
these are actually real in El Hiro Spain
there's over 26 000 hectares of them
that create food supplies for the
majority of Europe here we find sappa
working as a farmer to produce food and
outside of the tens we can see Russian
text now in our first film breakdown we
talked about how we thought that Japan
were the winners of World War III and
this is why they were seen in every
aspect of La at the arise that this was
done because of Asian superiority fears
that were prevalent at the time and
there were lots of Western organizations
scared that the East would take over
this is because lots of our products
were from Japan and China and I think
Ridley Scott cleverly placed this into
the movie now in this film it seems like
the Russians are now reeling which is
denoted by this text later on we see
some Holograms including a ballerina and
also the words cccp this implies that in
the Blade Runner universe that the
Soviet Union didn't split up and that
they now rule over America the words
that we see on the tent here actually
translated says Lina and this is a
reference to the campaign in the Soviet
Union where workers were sent out to
Farms this was in order to grow food and
we discovered that this is a
quote-unquote protein form which is
basically forming grubs because not many
animals left now in his home we catch a
piano and in the first film we learned
that Rachel had memories and Planet into
her to make her believe that she'd taken
lessons she played the piano at decades
in K later plays the E key to reveal a
hidden Russian box sucks and a photo
okay travels to Vegas he plays his same
e key as well and it's calling back at
that moment from the first film are the
scenes also a bigger tribute to that
movie then you might realize the first
movie was originally supposed to happen
like this and then he used the original
storyboards that readily and co-created
to map out this scene in it we had
Deckard traveling out to a farmhouse
where he killed the occupant and this
was to show how ruthless he was Deckard
waited in the house with a Boiling Pot
of soup on the stove and as the
replicant returned home and went to stir
it he was shot in the back by the
character this was without Descartes
saying a word and it was meant to show
us instantly how bad he was now as much
as I loved that first film we never
really get the impression that deckards
threw the scalp hunter that people make
him out to be this scene I think would
have added to it but it allows K to come
across as completely cold and also
remorseless saparettes is scalpel and we
later learned that this is the same one
he used to provide an emergency
C-section on Rachel she died during
childbirth but the baby was saved and he
plans the idea in case mind that he's
this way because he's never seen a
miracle he also says how does it feel
killing your own guy I don't retire my
own kind because we don't run now this
is obviously because Kay's generation
obeys entirely however we see him slowly
learning the empathy he needs to escape
k then takes his eye and he gets a call
from his boss played by Robin Wright
whether he's distracted after he notices
some buttercups at the tree and Robin
Wright actually played the character
Buttercup in The Princess Bride might be
a rich but Kay returns home and you
might notice that he's the only car on
the sky in case he missed our first
video This was done for a specific
reason and it's a show how the class
system still exists in this world the
elites have gone to space whereas those
casts to the side have been forced to
remain on Earth police have more power
than those on the ground as well and
this is why they all have flying cars
you know the score pal
you're not cops you're little people we
see this represented later on when Kay
returns home and he can actually catch a
VW Bug this happening approach also
mirrors how the first film handle things
and huge it out to Thomas flight who put
together a video of similarities this
includes the ice shot and also how the
vast and expensive skyscrapers are
initially approached we see the sea wall
here as well along with adverts for joy
and the LAPD building which looms
overall at this point we see the abuse
that K subjected to by the other humans
and we also get the first Baseline test
interlinked what's it like to hold a
hand to someone you love interlinked
interlinked did they teach you how to
peel finger to finger interlinked this
is designed to trigger an emotional
response from him by asking questions
that humans May deal with the language
here is based heavily around the pale
fire this is about discussing
Consciousness and what happens to it
after we die the film ends with Kay's
death and if replicants are indeed alive
then surely they go on the same Journey
that humans do when we pass the pale
fire is also the book that Joy holds up
when they talk about getting something
to read but joy says that she hates it
now from here we get a shot of the
street I can also see a sign advertising
off World Travel this is what was
present on the blimps in the first movie
and it attempted to lure people out to
the Stars we can also see people riding
on bikes which calls back to the first
movie and you might notice a cheeky Sony
advert as they distributed this movie
well what they Sony made this bloody elf
sometimes they don't make Trash with
Charlie
okay you shout out as he goes up the
stairs and we also see graffiti over his
door however inside he has his own
little bit of paradise and this is
alongside his AI girlfriend Joy now the
other thing Joy eventually does come to
care about k early on it's important to
bear in mind that she's very much a
product you can tell because there's
actually some subtle things that she
does and this is very much to upsell
things to K how's your day
I'm getting cabin fever this is done to
upsell the emanator and this will allow
her to roam around outside little does
she know that he's actually already got
this making me think that she suggested
it several times potentially as part of
her programming none of this gives her
Freedom it comes with its downsides as
this is actually how Love's able to
track him later on love asks if K is
satisfied with that product and this is
clearly in reference to Joy how about
after that she says something similar to
Joy and to me this comes with the idea
that case also approached too I say
you're also a customer
are you satisfied with our product
I do hope you're satisfied with our
product
I love you while this is of course the
one who builds the replicants in Ai and
thus he's very much having these two
products fall in love ajoy is very much
the evolution of Alexa and she rattles
Off song facts and acts like a 1950s
housewife did you know this song was
released in 1966 on reprise records
it was number one on the charts okay
blows some smoke through her and this
glitches the Hologram showing the RGB
color as needed to present Her Image he
gives her the emanator and at this point
we get several things about joy that
look like the menu on smackdown's
Creator wrestler her ethnicity is Cuban
much like Anna's in real life and her
height is also 168 centimeters which is
Anna's height too I'm not a stalker yeah
it's on Google now as the emanator
powers up we also get a line of legal
text to the right and this says I join
all of the Technologies connected to her
our property of the Wallace Corporation
we have the Wallace logo then pop up and
we get the idea that Joy doesn't really
belong to K the emanator then plays
notes from Peter and the Wolf
hmm
this is a Russian composition again
showing how the Soviet Union are the
rulers of everything the story itself is
also about hunting much like Kay's role
and in the end it comes with the moral
that heroes must take chances like what
we get in this story K takes Joy up to
the roof and it's possible that this is
a nod to the original book that the
first film was based on Deckard and that
owned a sheep which he kept on the roof
finding that he was collecting sculpts
to get enough money to buy a new being
goat this is just like okay saving up
money to buy the emanator and the first
thing that he does is take joy to the
top on the roof we see a bell board that
has a woman with white face paint on and
this is possibly calling back to the
women from the first film however
instead of being Asian she is Caucasian
potentially showing the switch to Russia
again there are Japanese letters up here
too and these actually translate to
Mobius Apartments huge allows to Alpha
Car 22 on Reddit for pawning out that
this is a nod to the artist Jean Mobius
Gerard who's working spider Elite Scott
when he was making that first film now
this is a really sensual moment and
watching two pieces of AI fall in love
makes me want to get my Alexa and Google
home and just bash them together it is
delete that bit
now it's such an interesting thing that
I hadn't really seen before but we see
how it has its downsides as K gets a
call that interrupts her this is from
his boss Joshi and when he returns to
work we learn that they've dug up
Rachel's bones I think this scene is
really important as it shows just as
similar replicants are to humans they
have the exact same stuff as us and not
indistinguishable except when you zoom
in close enough that you can catch a
serial number this is done to give us
the idea that there's not really any
defense between us and them they're just
said to be machines so we don't feel bad
enslaving them being able to have
children and therefore being even close
to human courses issues and the fear
about replicants reproducing could once
more cause a war the only control that
humans have is that we are the ones who
make them but if they can make their own
then there's gonna be no need for us
thus they could wipe us out and you can
see how the fear of Extinction would
cause Humanity to go and act
irrationally okay is ordered to kill the
child but he becomes conflicted over
this because being born means that it's
alive replicants have been told that
being born means they're real and it's
what gives them the self-perception that
they don't have a soul to be born is to
have a soul I guess you've been getting
on fine without one
that matter
a soul now getting political but I think
that replicants do have souls and at the
ending of the first film was very much
about giving that idea Dove symbolically
represent the idea of a soul and Roy
saying that it's time to die shows that
he was in fact alive anyway cut of the
city and we then see natari logo though
they're extinct now the corporation was
still going in the first film so it's a
nice little carryover to have the logo
popping up here K travels to the Tyrell
Temple and we learn this is now owned by
Wallace cut to love who's basically a
human trafficker selling slaves and
pleasure models to a Workforce in space
she suggests styling down the humanity
making them just blank shells love sees
herself as being more than just a
replicant k even remarks on how he named
her he named you
must be special
I'm here for Mr Wallace throughout the
film she's desperate to be seen as the
best of the best she seeks validation
from Wallace and every single aspect and
I think one of the reasons she gets
angry when killing Joshi is that she
sees a human he's not this is someone
who will protect their replicant more
than Wallace ever will with her it makes
her realize that he just sees has an
object Joe she's basically putting her
life on the line for what Society deems
as being a Tamagotchi however she still
protects K whereas Wallace would never
do that for her while this also refers
to her as an angel and this goes beyond
just her protecting K from the sky later
on the replicant that Wallace got
herself retire in the short film was
called Angel and he's likely carried on
this notion in his other right hand
replicants come the end of the film we
get a symbolic shot when K kills love
and the lights over his shoulder appear
almost like their angel wings the film
is also set in La which yeah City of
Angels a Love Takes K past and Nexus 8
models which we can't show because of
YouTube monetization one of them
actually resembles the engineers from
Prometheus though and the creative team
did this as a little not to Ridley Scott
to then get the vodkom test files from
the first film and this has a question
about the WASP planning on Rachel's hand
later on when Kay arrives in Vegas a bee
lands on his but he doesn't kill it
whereas Rachel says that she would this
is him potentially believing that he's
not a replicant and the movie does have
him questioning whether he's actually a
person who's been tricked into thinking
that he is one it sort of flips the
script on the first film as in that we
were questioning whether humans were
replicants whereas here were left doing
the opposite gonna be honest though I
didn't really think there was any
ambiguity because as soon as we've seen
K getting Batista bombed I knew that he
was a replicant but they do kind of go
back and forth in the movie now love
says that it's a nice being asked
personal questions as it makes one feel
desired she's just seen as a replicant
member of staff and it's likely that no
one ever asks for things because she's
just seen as a slave I do kind of sense
some flirting between her and K though
as she immediately follows It Up by
asking if he enjoys work
it is invigorating being asked personal
questions
desire do you enjoy your work officer
she's very much flirting with him and
likely trying to do what Rachel did by
asking questions of him may I ask you a
personal question sure have you ever
retired a human by mistake
love just can't get it right though
because her social skills just haven't
been developed now from here K goes to
meet Gaff from the first film I've seen
some talk on Reddit about his headrest
being a reference to Battlestar
Galactica and in that Universe they use
this to symbolize cutting corners and
doing things as cheaply as possible gav
has been left in what seems to be an
asylum and he says he could tell
something was different about Descartes
because of his eyes replicants are
identified by their eyes and they do
kind of play loose and fast with the
idea that Deckard could be one any idea
how I could contact him
retired retired is also a term that
means to kill a replicant and thus this
may be him hitting at that being the
case and we also create an origami Chief
bouquet and this of course carries its
own meaning in the first film he made a
chicken to symbolize Descartes turning
down the job initially and this was Then
followed by a man with an erection this
was after Deckard met Rachel and to
culminate with the Unicorn that could
hold a number of different meanings K is
given a sheep because he's just
following orders without question and
he's not special whereas the Unicorn is
I think the entire film is about K
realizing that he isn't really special
and this is quite a nihilistic thing
he's not the chosen one the love of his
life is potentially just programmed that
way and we'll talk about the hidden
symbolism in his death scene later on
now from here we go back to Wallace's
now we can see water reflecting on the
steps which is another not to Ridley
Scott he actually wanted a shimmering
pool in the Tyrell pyramid but the
production team they put their foot down
and spelled out why that wouldn't work
and apparently just said I want it
because it looks
Wallace says this an angel should never
enter the kingdom of heaven
without a gift can you at least
pronounce a child is born this is
language at Paul's from the Bible and
again it's given the idea that Wallace
views himself as a God and His
replicants are his angels He refers to
replicants as being born and this again
shows that he views them as actual life
they don't actually wore gray contact
lenses on set and this made it
impossible to see so he had to be
ushered around everywhere it's called
acting shut up now interestingly Danny
revealed that originally he wanted David
Bowie to play the role because of his
real-life eccentricities sadly though he
passed away in 2016 and would have been
Gravely ill when this film was being
shot now we learned that Wallace is
trying to create replicants that can
make their own children he brings in his
drones to look over a new prototype one
of them stays staring at love and this
is done to see her reaction to him
basically killing a newborn life form
Tyrell talks about how every
civilization is built on the back of a
disposable Workforce but that we lost
our stomach for using slaves because
he's unable to create rap applicants and
make children he can't spread out as far
as he wants to unless he feels that
humanity is trapped he stabs the
replicant in the abdomen and this is in
the same way that love kills Joshi later
on she too copies her master's
mannerisms and Wallace kisses the
replicant right before she dies this is
something that love also does with K
when trying to kill him showing how much
he wants to live up to Wallace now this
is actually a callback of the first film
as well and Roy kissed Tyrell just
before he murdered him now Wallace is
frustrated that Tyrell managed to create
replicants that could breed and this he
sends love out after K the best angel of
all
now at this point we jump back to LA and
catch the umbrellas in the street that
we used at the beginning of the first
film you can also see a hologram and
this starts up with a woman dancing in
it this is actually an idea mess and
it's a nice subtle reference to Joy
being customized and built for different
audiences you have the more classic
homewife that K has but there's also
this serious side of the AI that can be
fetishized too we can also see a screen
in the top right with Kay's face on it
too and this shows that the group are
actively looking for him now on the TV
wall we can see a screen that says
jiggity jig and this is what JF
Sebastian's doll said upon Him returning
home
yeah we also see pleasure bot in full
effect and see that they also speak
Russian which yeah I'm doing your
heading with that now Marriott stays and
says that she's never seen a tree before
and she starts to flirt with him but my
man's loyal to Joy now this party
returns to sappers and discovers the
tree has the baby's date of birth on it
witchy then Burns we later learn that
this date is inscribed at the bottom of
the horse too and this it makes him
begin to believe that he's connected to
it although it's difficult to make out
when we see it in the shadows we can see
that this horse actually has a horn in
the middle of its head meaning that this
is actually a unicorn tying back to the
ending of the first film I love kills
Coco and takes the bones of Rachel and
later on this is used to create a
duplicate version of her however just in
the same way we don't know if dinosaurs
had feathers or not Wallace isn't able
to get things like tissue right which is
why the eyes on green arcade tells Josie
about this wooden horse memory and we
see this playing out there's a little
clue here that this is actually Anna as
we see that she has long hair whereas
the boy is chasing her have shaving
heads later on when Kaye visits the
location we can see the girls there have
longer hair or as the boys are shaving
shown that the memory was of a girl now
Anna being outside here could show that
the immune deficiency thing that keeps
her confined to a room is in fact a lie
in this world I think knowing that
memories could be implanted would
actually make a question if yours were
real or not and we just discover that
she was told her parents went off world
as we know they are really Deckard and
Rachel's so it shows how her entire life
may be a facade anyway we once more see
the pale Fire book on the table and this
is the only book K owns because it's
likely all that he can afford again
paper is very expensive but the fact
that he has his shows how a line he is
on it for the Baseline test K travels
out to look over code and we see what
makes a replicant it's quite complicated
code and Joy says that she's more simple
existing of ones and zeros this is of
course binary code but K replies by
saying half as much but
twice as elegant sweetheart our Tyrell
said something similar in the first film
when he remarked on the replicant life
spans being camels that burned twice as
bright but half as long now from here
that led to the moral coal orphanage to
track down the records of the replicant
child we hit up San Diego and see it's
been turned into a dump which is a far
cry from the whale's vagina that it used
to be I'm out here K's Spinners attacked
with what I think is a kite that then
travels up into the clouds and gets
struck by lightning might not be that
and I'm probably wrong so yeah let me
know if you actually know because it
looks like that but it may just be a
standard EMP now Joy is shorted out
because of this and it's kinda
heartbreaking watching her glitch out
when trying to wake him up now as the
spinner is sworn we see how love once
more acts like a guardian angel raining
down missiles from the sky seeing her
killing countless people while getting
her nails done shows how detached from
Humanity that she is and her eyes are
covered during this to represent the
soul she lacks this is also from a God's
eye view and I think that it's ironic
these people will probably pushed out of
their jobs because of AI and they're now
being killed by it showing how much
technological advancements have stopped
our species now love is of course
keeping him alive and this is so that
you can find more out about the kid
anyway at the orphanage he meets Mr
cotton played by Lenny James James said
that cotton used to be a school teacher
and it was through this that he was
entrusted with the orphanage however
he's turned it into a child labor
Factory and he has children picking away
at the scrap metal from the dump to make
himself richer he tries to sell the kids
at first but when K Reveals His badge
his tune quickly changes however he does
say something interesting bigger than
you were trying to shut me down bigger
than you and they wouldn't
they were men at there and though we
don't know who this is it could be due
to him housing the replicant child it
may also be sapper due to his comment
about them being big and potentially
they tried to free Anna after she was
sent here we do know that people have
been snooping through his stuff recently
though and they likely went to him
because we discover he kept physical
records that weren't damaged by the
blackout he had a page torn out which
the child's data was connected to and
after noticing a horse ashtray Kay
decides to go to where his memory was I
were told in this film on the first the
replicants don't have memories of things
that really happen because it's illegal
if they were to encounter the location
in real life then it may cause an
existential crisis in which they
question their own identity ironically
Anna is a memory designer and though she
avoids using her own ones she implanted
some of hers into all the replicants
which ends up bringing them together
later on with Mariette we see her notice
the wooden horse and she's transfixed by
it possibly because it's also a memory
She carries okay then goes to see Anna
and we see we have photographing an
insect bugs make up a majority of the
memories and in the first film we heard
about Rachel's one which centered around
his spider and she then makes a birthday
cake and it's possible this is actually
Anna's due to it being a seventh
birthday party and her being locked up
in here when she was eight well there's
a bit of every artist in their work
and we learn and it tries to create
happy memories because the replicants
have to do such hard work but this
allows them to have something to look
back and smile on Anna being behind
glass also carries its own symbolism
with it and through the reflection we
get a really interesting shot as Anna
leans into her microscope K is frame
behind her and his reflection's much
darker making him almost appear like a
shadow he very much believes he's her
unless it makes sense symbolically that
he's now living in her Shadow now Anna
says the memory is real and she'd of
course instantly know due to it being
one of her own K travels outside of this
spot he'll eventually die at and at this
point he then catches a snowflake this
very much carries the true meaning of
the movie and it brings with a lot of
symbolism that Bells off the back of the
first film now in that Roy buddy
famously said that all his memories
would be lost like tears in the rain he
died with it pouring down on him and
this mirrors how K dies with the snow
coming down Roy died with his head down
whilst kale looks up and there's also
this metaphor lace just in the snow and
rain the movie is about one person
realizing that they aren't as special as
they think and we could all end up lost
like tears in the rain however we are
all unique just like every individual
snowflake is and though we'll get lost
we all leave things behind when we pass
now there is a class system in Blade
Runner that tries to pull others down
yep and none of us being special we
should all treat each other with
kindness though we are all our own
individual and unique people we are a
collective too and K dying realizing
that he is in special means that he's
willing to sacrifice himself to save
descart and his daughter how do you
thought the opposite he might not have
put himself In Harm's Way but he accepts
that even though he's unique he's no
better than anyone else I know people
think it's quite a nihilistic Viewpoint
to have the main character not be the
chosen one but I actually think it
carries its own positive meaning that we
should be nice to each other because
we're no better than they are K
realizing that Joy might not really love
him ends up leaving him completely
deflated but I think in the end he takes
a different Viewpoint in become coming
the hero I wanted to add that in here so
I'm not just describing the scenes but
yeah let me know below if you agree or
not okay it's called in after he fails
his Baseline test which means that at
this point he should be retired okay
Zone pretends he's just had a big
negative reaction to killing the kid and
Joe she gives him a pass because of the
emotional toll it could carry he's given
48 hours to pass his Baseline tests but
Upon returning home we find that Joy's
hired Mariette Mariette could be playing
on the word marionette and Joy uses her
as the puppet in this scene this love
scene is really astounding and though
they could have easily have cut this eye
to progress the story I think it adds so
much the effects are incredible here
with both actresses going back and forth
and I think it does show how much joy
really loves K she's gone beyond her
programming to actually gain a real
attachment to someone and clearly AI is
capable of Breaking Free of its
programming which K also embodies
however I do think he can totally take
this the other way as we cut to a
billboard of Joy saying she's anything
you want her to be this shows that it
may just be part of her to do things
like this again calling back to the idea
that she's programmed to love him the
book actually did something similar with
Rachel and we learned that she was
programmed to sleep with bounty hunters
to dissuade them from retiring
replicants a Marriott places a tracking
device in case code and this is how
later on they're able to track him down
now there's very much this idea of
Pinocchio lace through moments like this
with both being desperate to be a real
boy and girl personally I think this
really makes you question what it means
to be real because they both seem pretty
real to me but what they mean by that is
that they both want to be human now just
like how decades went to his snake
salesman in that first film we see Kay
visit a dealer called Dr Badger he tells
him to head to Las Vegas and we discover
that the dirty bomb was set off there
which was potentially detonated during
World War III now the orange look of the
city was actually inspired by a real
life event and this was meant to mirror
the dust storms that hit Sydney in 2009
I love this symbolism that we get here
and as K walks through the streets he
sees a giant head missing in eyes some
of the how the replicants remove theirs
he comes across beehives and this could
be being used in a similar manner to how
they are in German airports we learn
from Dr Badger that the area is thick
with radiation and bees are actually
used to show if there's high levels in
the area bees also exist in colonies and
they're given the bare minimum to
survive so they can keep everything
going this is similar to humanity who
are now forced to barely get by due to
so little resources remaining on the
planet okay guys looking for Deckard and
his first lines are from Treasure Island
I didn't happen to have a
piece of cheese about you now now this
is actually a no to the original Blade
Runner and in that there was a deleted
scene in which descart visited a man
named Holden who had been reading it the
line could also be significant due to
its meaning in the source material and
in that it's said by the character Ben
Gunn who spent years marooned on an
island upon seeing another human for the
first time this is what he says and Ben
very much shows these people that he
once used to be like them and that he's
what they could become which I think
deckard's also doing with K he
brandishes his old gun from the first
film and chases him into a showroom
replaying Elvis's hologram like Tupac at
Coachella this was betrayed by Elvis
tribute act Ben Thompson and his face
was then digitally replaced by the real
Elvis for the final film The Decade
starts punching hay and Harrison
actually hit Ryan in real life when he
was doing this if you pause on the last
one you can see Ryan's face reacting to
it as well as Ford looking shocked in
the background
smashed it like that like but now you
having that Elvis and cuts in with Khan
help falling in with you Deckard says he
likes his song and many have read this
as meaning that he was a replicant that
was programmed to fall in love with
Rachel the pair share a futuristic
bottle of Johnny Walker and this is
Samina Deckard Drank in the first film
k-spot's decades dog and you might have
noticed that it was actually standing in
the doorway when the pair first met K
says is it real
I don't know ask him and this is very
much tackling the themes of the film and
whether it really matters if the dog is
manufactured or not if you can't tell a
difference now an amazing bit of
attention to detail here comes from Ford
when we cut Decay drinking he holds all
four fingers on the glass like how a
normal person would when they were
drinking board however rests two fingers
below it and later on when he looks
through his binoculars we can see the
same two fingers drop down below it cut
back to the first film and these are
actually the same two fingers that Roy
broke at the end of the movie Deca tied
them up but he immediately went on the
run with Rachel after this so he never
got them properly checked explaining why
they're like this after all this time oh
you know I love Ford and I think it's
hilarious how a lot of the time he just
turns up to movie sets these days like
he's just woke up man just wears a gray
t-shirt throughout this film and I don't
even think that he even got his hair cut
for Rise of Skywalker he's a [__]
Legend though and this stuff just adds
to his charm okay starts up a jukebox
which plays Frank Sinatra this was
actually inserted as an homage to buddy
yorkin who produced the first Frank
Sinatra film and also the first Blade
Runner k then looks over some wooden
animals and a photo of Rachel which
carries an important meaning photos in
the first film were coveted by the
replicants because of their short life
spans photos kept a record that they
actually existed and this showed that
they were real a love forces sweep in
and they do a nice little touch with a
dog sensing them first before they
arrive K ends up running through a
marble wall and yet at no point was I
thinking this guy was really a human man
looked over some car before and read
like hundreds of lines of it in seconds
so you're [__] kidding if you think I
was buying any of that anyway bested by
love she mercilessly kills joy and
leaves k for Dad which is when he's
found by the rebels when they arrive at
the city we also get a nice little touch
and see that they've made their home in
a church here he meets Frazier and she
has the same accent as Anna tipping us
off to her raising her it feels
authentic and if you have authentic
memories you have
real human responses you must want me to
look up and to the left
I saw a miracle delivered
now she asks K to kill Deckard and the
only reason that he was hiding out in
Vegas was because Descartes could
identify Frasier she is the only one who
could identify Anna and thus in the end
he must be killed however Kay ignores
this and he allows Deckard in the end to
finally meet his daughter now back with
Wallace we see his deck and meets him
for the first time he grabs his hand
almost like how a priest talks to
someone and asks steckard where the
child is so that he can reverse engineer
them now we get a playback of his first
conversation with Rachel before she
walks out of the darkness like she did
all those years before it's artificial
artificial
of course it is
must be expensive
very
I'm Rachel
[Music]
Deckard
all these ears you looked back on that
day drunk on the memory of its
Perfection while I send further hints
that descard was a replicant but he also
throws other possibilities to not ruin
it for fans did it never occur to you
that's why you were summoned in the
first place designed to do nothing short
of fall for her right then and there all
to make that single
perfect
specimen that is if you were designed
now it is possible that the credits
actually tell us the truth and as the
names of the cast appear on screen the
replicant ones glitchy uncut however
Ford's name doesn't possibly suggesting
that he's in fact human but one thing he
does do though is that he moves back
when Deca goes close to him he's so used
to having everyone obey him that he
doesn't know what to do when someone
else stands up to him pain reminds you
the joy you felt was real I think this
can also be reflected in K who's just
felt the pain of Joy's death showing
that she was real Rachel is then brought
in but he resists a Temptation and it's
at this point I kind of realized that
Wallace was more devil than God siding
with him would very much be a deal with
the devil and he be able to control a
feature of humanity by making replicants
that obey him interestingly we do get a
moment in which Wallace raises his hand
and this was something that Tyrell did
in that first film although this look
like a mannerism that Jesus did when we
did that breakdown and then again
Hammer's home is idea of him being holy
now we get a gray moment in which Kay
and Deckard both parallel each other we
end the scene with his back turned to
the camera and this then cuts to Kaye
who's in the same position at this point
case presented with an advert but joy
but she doesn't measure up to what he
had much like how the fake child didn't
fake chill now best and basked in a blue
light he sees join realizes that he has
to stand for something Joy also has a
tagline everything you want to hear
slash C making him realize that he may
have been manipulated I still like to
believe that love was real but yeah let
me know below now the escort heads were
Deckard over the sea wall and in some
behind the scenes info the license plate
and Love's car can be scanned to read
Philip K dick the rain comes down and
then at this point Deckard notices K
coming through like Roy his salvations
come through the rain and K causes the
vehicle a crash which is when he tackles
love face to face love is of course a
human emotion but she's completely
devoid of it showing how twister
Wallace's Creations are from what's
intended the crashes allowed decades
debt to be faked unless he can go and
meet his daughter Anna Hayes hand is
also bandaged up and this is similar how
decades was at the end of the first
movie he then hands over the horse and
Decker goes in as he dies on the steps
really nice bit of attention to detail
here and if you look at the clothes you
can also see they have salt lines on
them due to the sea water now the ending
of this film and the previous one both
share similarities and in both films we
follow people who represent oppression
decade and Chao Hunters that kill
replicants and initially they don't
represent what a hero is now the first
movie culminates with Roy saving decade
even though he didn't have to deck it
was someone who killed the woman he
loved and his friends but he still
spared his life because he was better
than the humans this completely flipped
deckett's mind stayed and it allowed him
to go off and have a life with Rachel as
something happens here with K2 and he
saves decades so that he can have a life
with his child like Roy he decides to be
more human than human enough for
salvation when he was tasked with
killing deck by Frasier he too dies like
Roy but in the end he's made his life
mean something by Saving another the
entire movie is about case searching for
Humanity and in the end he finds it by
turning from a remorseless killer and is
someone who's willing to give up his own
life in order to protect others it's a
beautiful way to close out and we end
with the same music they used in Roy's
death tying the two films together and
that is the breakdown and I'm sure you
can guess that I've absolutely adored
going back through these two films and
if you missed our breakdown of the first
one then definitely make sure you check
it out we do know that a TV show is in
the works called Blade Runner 2099 and
it will be interesting to see if we
learn what happened with how they left
things off even though all the
characters will probably be long dead at
that point anyway I'm gonna return to
the alien franchise very shortly as I
know a lot of you wanted to torture me
with alien 3. before that though I want
to do The Exorcist and after that I
think I want to tackle Robocop and then
we're gonna go into the Terminator films
so make sure you stay subscribed for our
classic movie breakdowns if you enjoyed
this video then please hit the thumbs up
and if you missed our Blade Runner
breakdown that's on screen right now but
out of the way thank you for clicking
this I've been Paul you've been the best
I'll see you next time take care peace